with after today's result I've got a  twelve and two against the southeast  seven and one on the road against the  southeast play of the day  [Applause]  he had to throw that in a couple looks  here BAM throws it a little wide he has  to crank back watch how he doesn't dunk  it he's throwing it in he just spiked  that ball in how does that go in on that  angle if he doesn't throw it in  perfectly that hits the back of the rim  and goes flying about 15 rows into the  crowd that was uncanny finish look at  that huh lettuce isn't that's amazing my  and catching it on catching it on the  right and finishing with your left is  awkward - he's rearing back